so I sort of don't even know how to
introduce this first story today except
I guess to just start with the facts a
photographer caught a picture of Donald
Trump's handwritten notes that he had
made right after he finished giving just
a completely off the rails unhinged
press conference on Monday and in the
handwritten notes which were
photographed Trump had the terrorist
group al-qaeda written as Al CAI da all
one word more like a superfood berry of
some kind than the terrorist group and
right away when the world expressed
concern that the guys clueless the usual
defenders came out of the woodwork and
said listen just because you can't spell
doesn't mean you can't think he could be
incorrectly spelling really good ideas
it's ablest
to criticize the fact that he seems
unable to spell which is sort of extra
funny because when you hear from people
who seem to have no concerned about
disabled rights start to say you're
being mean to trump in an ableist way
because the guy can't spell that's weird
and it's also weird because it implies
that Trump has some kind of cognitive
disability which those same people have
to date denied is the case but this has
become popular recently I saw some
people recently explaining or attempting
to explain you know when you go online
and someone says your instead of you
apostrophe re it's totally irrelevant
whether they spelled something correctly
or whether they use the right version of
your or your they might just process
information differently they could still
have really good ideas these are still
people who we should be turning to when
it comes to political ideas and how the
country should be organized or whatever
there's no connection between their
spelling and grammar and anything else
the thing is this is not the case for
Donald Trump okay there are certainly
people that we could identify and say
hey you know what they have dyslexia and
here's how this is reflected but it
really doesn't seem to influence their
ability to think it's no indication of
the fact that they are limited or
ignorant or whatever else this is not
some mere isolated spelling mistake with
Donald Trump the press conference itself
was off the rails
the ideas that Trump espouses are off
the rails he has demonstrated himself to
be ignorant to foreign and domestic
policy and economic policy and and and
so many other things and it turns out
that he also doesn't seem to know that
al Qaeda al
- QA EDA is not spelled al CAI da this
is Red Alert insanity for a President of
the United States now I thought it was
actually a joke when I saw this I
thought that this was some kind of
Photoshop thing I I truly didn't believe
that Donald Trump had written down what
looks like Al sayyida on a piece of
paper as his notes but it is real and
this is the press conference in which
Donald Trump said that for ethnically
minority Congress women should go back
to where they originally came from their
original countries for which he was
ridiculed worldwide and this is all made
much worse when you realized that Donald
Trump's absurd and erratic comments
weren't actually off-the-cuff we often
say Trump should really stick to his
notes or the script or the teleprompter
that he criticized Barack Obama for
using but now relies on himself because
if he strays from it if he goes off the
cuff he goes off the rails
he had these ideas in his notes not only
al sayyida but also stuff about these
people and socialism and whatever else
and I hate to bring this up again only
because it's so obsessing to imagine
that this is what's going on obviously
this is renewing fears and concerns
about dementia or cognitive decline in
Donald Trump yeah Trump might just be a
bad speller in addition to being
completely ignorant and narcissistic and
xenophobic and racist and a sexual
predator but once again we do have to
confront the possibility that there's
cognitive decline here and every new
glimpse we get into the mind of Donald
Trump is only increasing the concerns
that this is more than just a guy who
can't spell and has bad ideas this is a
story about winning the birth lottery
okay Trump is a guy who if he were not
the son of a billionaire who gave Trump
a small loan of a million bucks to start
a real estate business would be the guy
Randi
about Jesus on the subway platform okay
were it not for being the CEO his entire
life like if Trump actually had to work
somewhere like a normal employee his
personality combined with his ignorance
would make him unable to hold a job in
any other country by the way Trump would
only be a billionaire real estate dude
he would not have become president of
the United States here in the United
States we have the sort of special
privilege as some might call it and I'm
using that term sarcastically we have
the special privilege of having 60
million people who thought this was a
good idea when they voted back in
November of 2016 or at least a better
idea than Hillary Clinton so this is a
combination this is a rare combination
that we have of someone who to go back
to the beginning of the story yes can't
spell and is a narcissist xenophobic
ignorant whatever who also only even had
the possibility of running for president
because of winning the birth Lottery in
the United States and had the benefit of
tens of millions of ignorant people in
the United States who thought it was a
good idea to vote for him it really
takes you know we talk about the
multiverse theories multiverse
hypotheses about you can imagine that
there are an infinite number of
additional universes in which everything
is possible where you are king of the
United States and whatever else we seem
to be in one of those wacky scenarios
where the stars have aligned so to speak
and Donald Trump has been able to become
president of the United States and it's
bad I'm glad that foreign leaders are
finally saying the extent to which it's
bad and they recognize it's bad now we
just have to make the right decision in
November of 2020 so continuing to do and
not as he says he will do Donald Trump's
2019 deficit is on track to reach the
one trillion dollar mark despite Trump
having told us you might remember time
and time and time again that he's going
to fix the deficit that Barack Obama
ruined that he will pay off the debt
altogether if given eight years in
office and the time that he thinks he
will need to do it now anyone who
understands these issues even remotely
knew that it was never going to happen
and in fact it's getting worse and worse
as I've said before though we really
need to be reframing our conversation
about this issue of debt and deficit
altogether so let's start with the facts
and then we'll get into the analysis and
the sort of meaning of all of this the
White House itself is now predicting
that the deficit is going to exceed a
trillion dollars this year the deficit
has never hit a trillion dollars in a
year now anytime we talk about these
numbers this is not a partisan this is
not to make this worse or not as bad as
it is this is just understanding when we
hear the deficit has never reached X
number of dollars before we need to
understand number one inflation-adjusted
numbers so that we're really comparing
apples to apples it's also important to
understand the size of the deficit as a
percentage of the economy's total size
and not in a vacuum just a few things if
we really want to do this seriously now
let's go back to what Donald Trump said
that he would do when Trump was a
candidate he said number one he would
eliminate the deficit altogether and he
would get us a surplus partially he
would do it by cutting taxes for the
rich and corporations which he said
would generate so much growth that
government Rett tax revenues would
actually expand and there would be all
this winning and we would have a surplus
and we would start paying off the debt
that obviously never happened and it's
important to understand like if you want
to talk about this at all I hate that I
have to do this but you really need to
understand the difference between debt
and deficit okay and I I apologize to
those who are sick of me doing this but
when I don't do this and even sometimes
when I do this the comments that I get
in reaction to debt and deficit stories
are so confused about the difference
between the two terms so these are not
the same things deficit is the one year
surplus versus deficit that the country
may have debt is the accumulated
deficits and surpluses over time so let
me give you an example if in year one of
a country you run a fifty dollar deficit
at the end of that year the country has
accrued a debt of $50 you exist for one
year you ran a fifty dollar deficit your
debt is now 50 bucks if in the next year
you run a 25 dollar sir
Plus what happens at the end of that
year is your debt has gone down from $50
to $25 right year one deficit is 50
bucks year to surplus is 25 bucks at the
end of year 2 the accumulated debt is
$25 you went $50 negative after year 1
and you paid off 25 of it with your
surplus in year 2 okay I mean III
apologize some people write in and they
say David please stop talking to the
audience like they're little kids that's
not what I'm trying to do every time I
do this people are confused about the
two issues so we were told that the tax
cuts would pay for themselves because
they would generate massive growth and
they would move us from having a deficit
each year to having a surplus which
would start chipping away at the
national debt eventually if Trump has
eight years in office completely paying
off the national debt now none of that
stuff is happening okay
the tax cuts have added to the deficit
increases in defense spending which by
the way were favored not only by
Republicans but even by many Democrats
as well those are increasing the deficit
and we are not on track we're not on
track to even pay off any of the debt
never mind pay it off completely in
eight years so those are the facts now I
do think every time we talk about this
we should consider whether it needs to
be reframed and what I mean by that is
the debt and deficit is a political
football okay Republicans say the most
important thing is paying off the debt
and balancing the budget when there's a
Democrat in the White House regardless
of whether that Democrat has actually
slowed down deficit growth which Barack
Obama did when Republicans are running
they run on promises to do this really
important thing start paying off debt
generate a surplus but then when they
are in office as we saw under george w
bush as we're seeing in a cartoonishly
exaggerated fashion under donald trump
they just explode the deficit and they
always claim that they're doing it they
either deny that they're doing it even
though we have the numbers and that's
what we see or they will argue
that there were extenuating
circumstances whereby it made sense to a
deficit spend like for example when we
decided we were going to heroically
spread democracy to Iraq and or punish
Iraq for their non existent involvement
in 9/11 right that the reason we it made
sense to spend all that money in Iraq
changed once we figured out Iraq had
nothing to do with 9/11 but still we
were given reasons why it made sense so
what we have today in the end is an
unsurprising status quo we were told
before Trump was elected what he wants
to do with tax policy is not going to
generate all of this winning and growth
and start paying off the debt with
surpluses in fact it's going to increase
the deficit that is exactly what
happened none of this is surprising so
that gets us to the question of if and
how Democrats should talk about this on
the campaign trail because on the one
hand Trump made promises and he broke
the promises and he's doing the opposite
of what he promised to do it seems as
though exposing that on the campaign
trail for the eventual Democratic
nominee would be a worthwhile thing but
on the other hand we know number one
that it's just a political football we
know number two that in reality the
narrative over deficit bad surplus good
cutting spending good or whatever else
it's not actually a modern and nuanced
understanding of debt and deficit what
we should be asking in reality is when
does it make sense for governments to
deficit spend and when doesn't it make
sense so do we want a deficit spend to
line the bank accounts of the already
rich and corporations including just
providing money for them to buy back
stock the answer is no do we want the
deficit spend to improve Society for
large numbers of people improve their
ability to live good healthy lives have
access to health care work jobs that
they like without being tied to mediocre
health insurance programs okay now we
have something to talk about so I think
that it is important for Democrats not
to ignore the issue of debt and deficit
but we can't allow the right to continue
framing the narrative because they win
they talk about it one way when it's a
Democrat in office they take office then
they just say oh no the numbers aren't
actually what they are you can't
the numbers that were actually getting
from from the Congressional Budget
Office and from the Treasury they win
with the framing that we have and lastly
please please please can we stop falling
for this stupid idea that tax cuts for
the rich are so good for the economy
that they reduce the deficit and
actually increase government revenue we
didn't even need another example we had
plenty of examples before Donald Trump's
tax reform plan but we can now add the
Trump tax reform plan to the list of tax
cuts for the rich and corporations that
did not cause so much growth that they
paid for themselves my question to you
is do you think Republicans even believe
this idea that tax cuts for the rich pay
for themselves or do they know that it's
BS but just keep repeating it because
these are the tax cuts that they want
that's my question to you today let me
know what you think this next story is
one of the funniest things that has ever
happened on this show I believe that I
have caught extremists right winger and
proud boy founder Gavin McInnes calling
into the show pretending to be someone
else in order to promote his new program
last week I got a call during live calls
from a guy who said hey my name is Jim
David have you heard about Gavin McInnes
new show he interviews left-wingers you
should go on his show you should own him
and I didn't really think much of it the
caller said he had a subscription to
Gavin McInnes his show and then after
watching all of the videos he cancelled
it and because I'm in the media space
and I've heard of Gavin McInnes his new
show it didn't sound obviously weird to
me but after the fact I started thinking
you know the truth is nobody's really
heard of Gavin McInnes his new show
especially people on the left it is sort
of weird to imagine that a left winger
is gonna go and pay for a subscription
to Gavin McInnes show and over the
weekend a bunch of people on our
subreddit started posting that hey David
that sounded a lot like Gavin himself
who called you a sort of mild Canadian
accent that was Gavin and is David
playing along or is David not realizing
it so I sent it over to my manager who
knows about this show and he said yeah
it does sound a lot like Gavin McInnes
I've gone back and listened to the call
again and I believe that this is Gavin
McInnes
and this is hilarious for a few
different reasons but first let's listen
to part of the call just so everybody
knows what I'm talking about
okay let's go next to our caller from
the two-five three area code who's
calling today from two five three hey
David it's Jim and I just wanted to say
a longtime listener first-time caller
loved ya and I just wanted to talked
about the green New Deal and just see
what ideas you had about maybe getting
that pushed through and also a guy I
despise came up on my YouTube the other
day on the commercial Gavin McInnes on
this new show free speech and I was
trying to click out of it right away and
then I'll son I saw dr. Cornel West and
Mark Lamont Hill on the show yeah and I
actually checked it out and it's a cool
show in regards to just liberals nailing
Gavin and it was so awesome watch
especially Mark Lamont Hill I cancelled
my subscription because I saw all the
shows but I just thought it'd be awesome
if you could get on his show and destroy
him for so holy canceled your
subscription to what oh I signed up just
to watch the dr. Lamont Hill oh I see
and Cornel West sure so clearly the
caller is someone who's very comfortable
on calls like this that's not really
evidence that it's Gavin McInnes
he does seem to know a little bit too
much about Gavin McInnes new show
despite the fact that like no leftist
has even mentioned this program to me
ever and no leftist really seems to be
aware of this program he claims that he
subscribed to it just to see an
interview with Mark Lamont Hill which is
sort of hard to believe that that's what
somebody would do and then I went and
listened to other interviews with Gavin
and it sounds like this is Gavin McInnes
there's a slight Canadian accent when
you listen to the pronunciation of some
words the real Gavin is Canadian I
actually was able to get in touch with
former personal friends of Gavin McInnes
and said just tell me what you think is
the caller Gavin they all said
had many phone conversations with Gavin
99.9% that is Gavin McInnes the name Jim
that was used matches another data point
that I was able to find related to
people associated with Gavin McGinnis I
don't know how else to kind of say that
part we also backtrack the phone number
that this individual called from the
phone number again matches a known
location for where Gavin McInnes lived
for a long time so basically I believe
there is a 99.9% chance that Gavin
McInnes is personally calling other
programs and under the name Jim reminds
me of what was Trump's fake guy Daniel
Miller or Trump had some name he used to
call what when when he would call other
places about himself and there's a few
takeaways number one Gavin McInnes truly
seemed so desperate to get attention for
his show that he's sitting around
calling shows like mine when I opened
the phone lines to mention his own show
that's pathetic now second why not have
someone else call like it would be
hilarious if a hundred people from my
audience started calling conservative
shows and mentioning the David Pakman
show that would actually be really funny
it would annoy the right-wing hosts I
would get those clips I would play them
but me just calling a show and
mentioning my own name that's a lot less
funny and interesting but it also goes
to show because I'm totally clueless and
I wouldn't even recognize Gavin's voice
I actually thought maybe there is some
left winger in my audience who actually
signed up and paid for Gavin McInnes
show to watch Marc Lamont Hill which
upon any amount of inspection doesn't
sound right at all now here's the the
situation that's going on behind the
scenes this is not random what's going
on behind the scenes is that Gavin
McInnes is program I don't know where
they get the money but they are offering
to pay guests to come on now this is not
typically done we have never paid a
guest we've had what 1,500 interviews
that have done we've had like two or
three people ask for money hope we've
never paid we just never pay for guest
every time I appear on CNN Fox News I'm
never paid for those appearances okay
the Gavin McInnes program is apparently
so desperate to get people to appear on
this program that they reached out to me
through my manager
offered I'm not gonna say how much but a
lot of money for me to appear on the
program so what took place here was not
random promotion what appears that
happened is that knowing that there is a
conversation taking place with my
manager about will David Pakman appear
with Gavin McInnes Gavin thought hey
here's an idea
I'll call David as Jim and pretend to be
a leftist who really wants to see David
appear on Gavin McInnes show this is
absolutely nuts that this is going on
there are other progressive hosts who I
won't name because I don't know if
they're going public with it who have
also been approached by this program and
offered money to appear and my manager
had the hilarious idea of if the number
isn't spoof like if I could actually
call the number back and and speak to
Gavin say hey Jim you called me on the
David Pakman show
I just wanted to tell you I I actually
am thinking of appearing on that show
just kidding Gavin this is you right
why'd you call me why did you call me
live on the air let me know what you
think absolutely stunning
bizarre and outrageous that this is
what's going on but this is where things
are apparently for Gavin McInnes at this
point in time okay this next story is so
damn funny that it's actually difficult
for me to put into words marianne
williamson is running for the 2020
Democratic presidential nomination she
has no chance I mean she's polling so
low that she's not even in the top 20
candidates in recent polling summaries
now she's a little bit wacky she has a
long history of being a sort of New Age
self-help guru I've interviewed her on
the program before but she also has lots
of completely reasonable and and
mainstream left-wing views which I agree
with and many of the people in our
audience would agree with there is also
a cultural critic and arbiter of Big
Ideas named Dave Rubin who is all about
discussing ideas and he's like a sort of
center-right kind of guy and he
interviewed Marianne Williamson and she
truly made him look so uninformed and
did it so easily like without even
breaking a sweat with no visible effort
debunking all of Dave Reubens attempts
to put her in some sort of current corn
and it was really a pleasure to watch so
I want to look at a couple of these with
you one popular sort of meme or false
notion that the right has been pushing
is that we should be giving Donald Trump
credit because he decided not to bomb
Iran and it's such a dumb talking point
because if it ignores the reality that
Trump is the one who made the decision
to bomb Iran in the first place and then
he erratically cancelled it last minute
after someone said hey you know 150
people are likely to die because of this
right and Bernie Sanders had a really
good analogy on this when he was asked
shouldn't Crump get credit for not
bombing Iran but Bernie said this is
like if you set a trashcan on fire and
then you put the fire out and you say
hey everybody I did a great thing
I put the trashcan fire out it's like
well you set the fire in the first place
so what kind of credit do you really
deserve for that so marianne williamson
destroys this talking point easily
points out that Trump is pulling us from
the nuclear deal that Trump's pulling us
from the nuclear deal better said was
the real problem I know you wouldn't
want to give it to him but does Trump
deserve some credit for not doing that
strike if you get it you got a call a
minute before and in terms of Iran no it
was the president who got who recklessly
removed us from the Iran nuclear deal
that is what led up to that the
president taking us out of the Iran
nuclear deal out of a situation that was
an international leveraging where by all
indicators Iran was that we know of the
Iran was compliant so now they've said
the other day that they're going to go
on and enriched uranium beyond what the
agreement called for because we had
pulled out no I cannot give the
president any credit for what's
happening with Iran
the fact that he was about to do
something so unbelievably reckless
because let me tell you something given
the size of the Iranian army alone you
think Iraq was a catastrophe nothing
compared to what war with Iran would
look like so obviously some hero we
don't know exactly who it was but we
know someone within the higher echelon
of either his administration is national
security apparatus or the military
talked him out of it that we can be very
thankful to this person whoever they
were this is really fun I have to
and I love watching these clips it's
just so so funny to watch the breakdown
because you've got kooky Marianne
Williamson just easily exposing the
absurdity of these questions from Dave
Rubin so here's another one another one
of these ideas that sort of being pushed
on Democrats is the idea that the
Democratic 2020 presidential candidates
are for open borders and of course not a
single Democrat has said anything about
open borders and this is so funny
because when marianne williamson points
it out Dave Rubin says well okay they're
not saying they're for open borders but
it sort of seems like that's what their
policies are all about and marianne
williamson is just having none of it
okay a couple more quick we'll try to do
them quick it seems like everyone's kind
of veering to some version of open
borders that's not her one candidate
well they won't say but the policies oh
you don't say it but you really mean
ways is that is that healthy honorable
debate of course no one has said
anything about open borders policies and
this is actually what they say we're not
supposed to do when it comes to saying
people are racist except here it's
really a cut and dry policy thing so let
me explain what I mean by that the right
loves to say even if someone says
something that sounds racially
insensitive or it could be xenophobic or
racist you don't really know what's in
their mind so you can't call them racist
you don't know their true motivations
for saying that thing that might sound
racist so you shouldn't call them racist
here dave rubin is saying okay even
though no one has actually said they
want open borders it's okay to infer
that therefore open borders apparently
because what they're against caging kids
at the border they're against deporting
daca recipients who were brought to the
United States by their parents through
no fault of their own when they were
minors and then lastly dave rubin tries
to I guess call out marianne williamson
for making an analogy between the
holocaust and slavery in the united
dates as horrible horrible events which
is funny because the right claims to be
against the oppression Olympics this is
one of their big things the right says
you know I'm against ranking oppressive
events I'm against ranking what group
what demographic group is more or less
oppressed or deserving of help in
society okay fine
but here is Marianne Williamson who
seems to have to explain that to Dave
Rubin well well do you think there's a
little bit of a risk in sort of I mean a
couple of times you're referencing the
genocide of the Jews to slavery seems
like a little bit of a slippery slope
there now I don't even know how we can
say that actually and I say that as a
Jew if you read up much on slavery
yeah we're talking objec slavery day I
mean nobody's in a contest nobody has a
monopoly on human suffering this was
object slavery there's always a risk to
equating civil rights catastrophes
because it's true there's no two events
that are exactly the same events take
places events take place in different
places and at different times in history
so to say two events are the same or
basically the same or mean the same
thing it's a little bit risky but
American slavery was one of the worst
thing that's happened and the Holocaust
is one of the worst things that has
happened in human history on this planet
so this may have been like the best
possible thing to ever happen to
marianne williamson scam Payne she's
still polling at zero and it doesn't
even seem like that many people have
seen this interview but it was really a
pleasure to watch and I got some emails
after the last debate this this is
really weird after the the democratic
debate a few weeks ago I got some emails
from people saying hey David
I think Marianne Williamson actually did
the best in the debate I think Marianne
won the debate
here's links to some youtubers who agree
with me and I was certain it had to be
some kind of satirical thing like back
when Howard Stern's audience was trying
to vote for Sanjaya a candidate on
American Idol even though the kid
couldn't sing just because it would be
funny to support someone who has no idea
what's going on but apparently it was
real and a lot of people actually seem
to be claiming that in syria's in some
kind of
'we marianne williamson won that first
debate she holds some of the right
positions on a number of issues but she
is quite out there and certainly not
somebody I could see getting behind
given the other people that are in the
2020 Democratic slate of possibilities
let me know what you think make sure
you're following me on instagram at
david pakman and while you're there
follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show right
back after this many of you are not
going to believe what I'm going to tell
you today unless you've actually been
following the story in which case you
will absolutely believe it
YouTube demonetised 75% of our video
clips that we uploaded yesterday from
yesterday's program yesterday's show
that we did for you which we spent all
day producing of course in filming and
editing and all of that stuff contained
eight separate clips that we uploaded to
YouTube and upon uploading them six of
the eight or 75% were instantly
demonetized by YouTube's algorithms 75%
of the work we did yesterday the content
that we spent all day producing was in a
fraction of a second deemed not
advertisers friendly and thus unable to
earn any revenue for us on YouTube so I
want to be really clear here about what
I am saying and about what I'm not
saying I'm not saying that we have a
legal issue on our hands here let me be
clear I'm not saying YouTube can't
choose to monetize or not to monetize
whatever they want but let me also be
clear that we're playing by the rules
and this is not how the system is
supposed to work
we don't do profanity on our channel we
don't do violent and gory images we
don't harass people on the basis of
their sexual orientation or other
characteristics we don't bully people we
don't Doc's people or anything like that
we produce FCC safe progressive news and
commentary and while we're supposedly
playing by all of YouTube's rules more
and more of our content as being
demonetized so yesterday we produced the
show we paid salaries to our staff we
paid studio rent
we paid utilities we paid connectivity
we paid health insurance but the clips
75% of them make
on YouTube hundreds of thousands of
views yesterday from these clips that
make no money on YouTube so this is a
systemic issue and notice bi I don't
want to be misquoted there are articles
that now are there are media outlets
following my coverage of what's going on
on YouTube and they have started to
misquote what I am saying I am NOT
saying we are being demonetised for
being left-wing or progressive okay the
right has preached sob stories for years
about the anti right-wing bias on
YouTube and everywhere else I am NOT
saying this is anti left-wing bias the
evidence that I've found is that this is
anti independent bias and pro corporate
bias within the news and politics base
on YouTube so I think I just have to
kind of get real with you here about the
situation I had to reach out to our
partners this week and basically say
this may never be resolved okay this may
simply be the new normal and we need to
kind of reposition our expectations
around the reality that this may never
be fixed because again I don't think
YouTube believes anything is broken
I don't believe YouTube thinks there is
anything to fix here this is the system
they want because it's safe for them
because their advertisers like it
there's also what appears to be a
growing issue of people being
unsubscribed from our channel and others
that are independent news in politics
and I am seeing this in the analytics
I've received hundreds of emails from
people who say David I've been a
subscriber for a month I've been a
subscriber for a year I've been a
subscriber for five years to your
YouTube channel I went to your channel
today because I didn't notice any of
your videos on my home page and I
noticed that the subscribe button was
enabled meaning I was able to click
Subscribe because I had somehow been
unsubscribed from your channel now I
know a lot of people are going to hear
me say this and they'll email me and say
David this is happening to me as well
I've already told you too about it I've
told them about it 10 times all I can
say is make sure you're subscribed right
now I mean check right now if you're
watching on youtube and click the
subscribe button if you aren't if you're
listening on the radio or to the podcast
or whatever consider going to youtube
and subscribing to our channel there as
well so I'm exploring many
other options to try to deal with this
issue that we're experiencing the most
direct is not you know moving our
content to some platform with no
audience sadly I know people email me
they say David start uploading to X Y or
Z website moving our content to web
sites where the content isn't monetized
and there's nobody watching is not a
solution to the problem okay
so what's important to understand is if
we didn't have any other revenue sources
we might be in a position to have to
change our story choices in order to
save our revenue and what I mean by that
is if we didn't have revenue coming in
through membership or through patreon I
might have to start each day thinking
okay here's the six stories I want to do
but four of those are likely not to make
any money on YouTube I guess I'll pick
some different stories I would never
want to do that that is the death of
independent media the whole point here
is we cover what we believe to be
important and this is how these
monetization algorithms set the agenda
and drive the narrative by making
certain content financially
unsustainable so that's the freedom that
we get when people support us directly
and as more and more people contribute
via direct membership and patreon you
are basically buying us a little sliver
of immunity from having to even think
about making decisions like here's the
stories I want to cover but they're not
going to make any money maybe I'll pick
some stories that YouTube's algorithm
would find to be brand safe I can't
afford to spend all day researching and
filming and editing and having our staff
do that and pay salaries and health
insurance and rent only to lose out on
the monetization so as I've said it
before I'll say it again
the way to fix this is simply to fund
the shows you like directly okay become
a member
ww join pakman.com it's really cheap
it's really quick you get cool stuff but
you buy us immunity from this disastrous
situation that's taking place there is a
discount code for membership this is
20/20 which will save you 40% if you
want to do something else you can go to
patreon.com/scishow especially if you
already are giving to other producers on
patreon throw us a dollar a month throw
us $2 a month it really does make a
difference
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
don't even really know how to start
today other than to tell you that it's
okay to say that Donald Trump is racist
that's really something we need to talk
about today it has to be discussed in
order to take power back from the right
on this issue because the right has
waged a really effective war against
saying people are racist they've done
this for years actually and the reason
is clear there's a ton of racism on the
right explicit and implicit if they can
stigmatize the calling out of racism the
saying that someone is racist
they are mostly helping themselves this
doesn't mean racism and xenophobia don't
exist on the Left I've talked about
anti-semitism on the left but as a
political strategy this is something
that disproportionately benefits the
right be being able to say you're
calling someone a racist that's the
problem and they've used a few
strategies in order to do this one
literally can't be refuted when they say
racism is what's deep in someone's mind
or heart and no matter what somebody
says you don't really know whether deep
down they are racist in their hearts and
minds so you shouldn't call anyone a
racist because no matter what it seems
as though they believe you don't really
know deep down in their heart of hearts
what they believe this is a joke because
it's completely unfalsifiable it's it's
it's possible that someone is acting
like a racist and saying racist things
and suggesting racist policy but that
they're merely acting and that deep down
they don't actually believe any of those
things but that's the same way that you
can't know for sure if someone is a
narcissist from their media presence
because they could be acting but think
about Donald Trump we have decades of
Donald Trump's interviews and actions if
your argument is he's only been acting
like a narcissist for 40 years and we
can't possibly know whether he actually
is one it's a really weak argument
because we could never really know one
way or another even if we asked Trump
hey listen you've said and done all
these things it seems like you're a
narcissist but
deep down are you really whatever his
answer is could also be alive so that is
just a dead end path to really figure
out whether someone is X Y or Z but the
more important thing is that when we're
talking about public figures that
dictate policy in particular what
matters is what they say and do publicly
in the sense that if I'm not personally
racist but I run a campaign on racist
ideas and coalesce racist voters around
me and I have xenophobic and racist
ideas about crime and IQ and cleanliness
and whatever what difference does it
make if somewhere deep down in secret in
my house at night I'm not actually
racist my public persona is a racist one
and that is what is important and media
have fallen for this media are often
afraid to call people racists or
xenophobes because Republicans have
really successfully run this campaign of
criticizing those who spot racism and
xenophobia now another strategy is they
say well you're actually the racist for
seeing race in this issue you are seeing
race and what someone said when it
didn't have to be that way you must be
the one who is racist identifying racism
and calling it out is the real racism
this is the second strategy that that
strategy that the right has employed in
order to try to insulate themselves from
their racism and xenophobia
it's another failed laughable argument
it's like the childish whoever smelt it
dealt it thing about farting I mean
literally saying if you believe there is
racism and if you see race you are the
racist is like in the sandbox or the
playground saying whoever smelt it dealt
it it's it's silly and childish and I
can't believe that it actually passes as
an argument in some political circles in
the United States so with that out of
the way let's now look at Donald Trump's
record because people saying oh his his
friends are black and he likes black
pizza guy Herman Cain or his daughter
converted to Judaism let's look at
Trump's public
of actions and statements remember
during the Central Park five case Donald
Trump believed that five black kids
committed a rape that they didn't commit
and actually spent money for an ad
claiming that the death penalty should
be reinstated specifically for them and
Trump attacked them even after they had
been exonerated but meanwhile he had no
problem with the deal that is outgoing
labor secretary Alexander Acosta struck
with serial child sex assault er Jeffrey
Epstein Donald Trump led the birther
conspiracy which questioned whether
Barack Obama was truly born in the
United States on the basis of supposed
to regularities with his long-form birth
certificate this was a racist conspiracy
theory furthered and fomented by racists
Donald Trump was at the head of the pack
when it comes to that Trump has been
targeted by the Justice Department in
the United States for racist housing
practices against people of color at
buildings that he owned or managed in
New York City Donald Trump attacked the
judge who was presiding over a case
involving Trump University saying that
because the judge is Mexican and the
judge had Mexican parents because the
judges of Mexican descent
they can't possibly be impartial
arbiters of trumps case which is of
course completely an absolutely
outrageous
Trump has mocked the genocide of Native
Americans in the United States Donald
Trump suggested that american-born
members of Congress should go back to
their quote original countries which is
extraordinarily racially tinged
xenophobic language and sentiment Trump
referred to poor countries with high
non-white populations as I guess we can
say it now but I won't just not get any
of our stations in trouble s whole
countries this includes Haiti El
Salvador and African countries Trump
once said immigrants from Haiti all
quote have AIDS and that Nigerian
immigrants would quote never go back to
their huts so listen is there ever going
to be anything Trump does that will
convince a racism denier that Trump is
racist there is
if something walks like a duck though
and it talks like a duck and it smells
like a duck it's probably a duck and
that's exactly what we have here now
again some will hear me say this and
they'll say David you're inferring
Trump's racism you don't really know
what's in his mind you can't read his
mind and know what's in there well
generally people say what's on their
minds when they don't they usually say
things that make them look better than
what's in their minds not drastically
worse so we just can't be afraid to call
things what they are especially when
world leaders around the world are not
holding back anymore Nancy Pelosi called
it xenophobic British politician David
Lammy called it 1950s racism from the
White House check out his tweet quote
Donald Trump telling four ethnic
minority American Congress women to go
back where they originally came from
nineteen fifties racism straight from
the White House any British politician
fit to serve as Prime Minister would
condemn Boris Johnson will you getting
into internal British politics as I told
you yesterday British Prime Minister
Theresa May called a quote completely
unacceptable the First Minister of
Scotland Nicola Sturgeon tweeted quote
the President of the United States
telling elected politicians or any other
Americans for that matter to go back to
other countries is not OK and diplomatic
politeness should not stop us saying so
loudly and clearly London Mayor Sadiq
Khan said on a radio show in the last
couple of days quote I've heard it from
racists and fascists never from a
mainstream politician here you have the
president of the USA using that same
sort of language and Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau has also
denounced Donald Trump's comments saying
quote I think Canadians and indeed
people around the world know exactly
what I think of those comments this is
not how we do things in Canada a
Canadian is a Canadian is a Canadian and
lastly Belgian politician
Guy Verhofstadt said quote Trump's
racism is sickening so they're calling
this for what it is we can also call it
for what it is but and here is the
important but and this is what is not
maybe being discussed as much as it
should you need to understand
you call this what it is that this may
be no accident but actually part of the
Trump Pence re-election plan and we
should just understand that fully I'm
not saying don't call racism racism I'm
just saying let's understand the full
scope of what's going on here
Heather Parton also known as digby wrote
a really good piece in salon and she
says this is a strategy that the
republican party of 2019 actually
believes will get Donald Trump and Mike
Pence re-elected and it may because
there is this bigger environment of Pro
white Pro Christian nationalism that is
all part of what even if the details
sound bad right when we Cajun kids
sounds bad telling Americans to go back
to their original countries to some
people that sounds bad it's painting a
very favorable right-wing nationalist
picture of the Trump administration
meant to get him reelected so put it all
together right refugee camps at the
border which we would condemn as a
country if they were happening elsewhere
read me xenophobia on Twitter against
mostly american-born members of Congress
who happen to be ethnic minorities
stoking fears of violent criminal aliens
while undocumented immigrants we know
commit crime at lower rates than
american-born citizens Mike Pence
showing up at border detention centers
and looking as the unemployment ik that
he is Trump announcing that ice raids
are going to start quote rounding up
alleged criminals who simply haven't
been caught yet we're on the left so we
see this and we imagine oh if people
simply find out that this is what
they're saying and doing they're not
going to vote for them that's not how it
works
we're on the Left we don't understand
how a lot of these right-wingers see
this stuff this is a package of
so-called being tough on immigration the
tweets the child cages all of this stuff
may well get Donald Trump reelected
because the right absolutely loves the
tough on immigration image 2020 is going
to be a mess partially it's going to be
a mess because of voter suppression
partially it's going to be a mess
because of the seeding of doubt
whether any results that show Donald
Trump losing can be trusted that's
already something Trump is ginning up
but it's also going to be a mess because
Trump ist's will be publicly voting for
what we are seeing Trump do and say day
in and day out including the racism and
the xenophobia so the only path forward
is removal with such overwhelming voter
turnout that even the voter suppression
and the Electoral College which is
stacked against the left and the rampant
unhinge xenophobic nationalists cannot
get Trump reelected and it's really
simple how it works if we can't do it
it's another four years of Trump that is
increasingly the way it's looking to me
I hate to say it okay we cannot convince
them to change their minds so the only
way to get rational people to help us
win this thing is to get non voters who
already agree with us to vote okay
everybody talks about this election will
hinge on turnout
it will literally hinge on turnout and I
don't know how to get the turnout up
we're going to talk about that later in
the week a little bit but it's what has
to be done
we don't have corporate media on our
side yesterday I told you that much of
the Trump xenophobic go back to your
original country stuff is meant to
divide the left the Trump Republican
strategy is throw red meat at them
divide the left make the eventual
Democratic nominee toxic meanwhile fire
up his own base with xenophobic racist
commentary corporate media is falling
right in line with debates about the
substance of Donald Trump's stupid
tweets instead of the role that they are
meant to play in influencing the
discussion and of course keeping Trump's
scandals out of the news so this is
really bad this is possibly as bad as it
has been and I hope that you'll
understand what's going on and that way
you'll be working with us in trying to
effect change in 2020 and just as
importantly in 2022 in which the Senate
will actually be up for grabs for
Democrats it won't be in 2020 we need to
be thinking about all of these things
but in order to do it we need to
understand exactly what it is that
Donald Trump is doing with this
commentary and in the end it's okay to
call racism racist
we've just got to understand the role
that it's playing and helping to get
this guy reelected
let me know what you think of the way
this is all fitting together I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me on Twitter
at D Pakman and follow the show on
Twitter at David Pakman show